okay hi everybody Welcome um just want
to say that it's my first time in NC
Oslo and I'm so excited to be here uh it
really is an amazing uh an amazing event
um so as I said my name is Dena and I'm
going to talk to you today today about
etw and all of the cool things that you
can do with it so etw is a monitoring
framework so the first thing that we're
going to do is that we're going to talk
a little bit about the challenges that
face when we try to use traditional uh
performance and profiling
tools and then we're going to introduce
edw uh and see what you can do with it
and how it addresses all of these
challenges that we have using
traditional tools um and then what we're
going to do is that we're going to
embark on a very long demo or rather
multiple short demos through which I
will try to show you some and definitely
not all of the things that you can do
with etw and which tools are are
available to you for this
purpose so let's begin as I said the
first thing that I want to do is talk
about the challenges there are many uh
profiling tools out there but I think
that one of
the most um problematic uh issue with
these tools is that they're usually very
invasive uh a lot of them actually
inject their code into your application
you know so that they can profile
whatever it is that you're doing um and
so that means that you have to recompile
your code or at the very least most of
the times you will need to restart your
application and these two together cause
quite a large overhead uh for example if
you're familiar with the Intel parallel
Studio profiler it's really a great tool
but the lowest level of profiling that
it gives you causes an an overhead of a
factor between 2 to 20 if I remember
correctly and that means that if you
have let's say a one minute scenario
that you want to profile then let's say
on average it's going to take about 10
minutes to run okay maybe we can live
with that but what if it takes about
let's say 5 minutes just to get to that
point in your application where you want
to start
profiling well obviously that's not
going to
pass now the next problem that we have
is even if the overhead is
inconsequential and we don't want we
don't mind waiting and all that still in
some cases we just can't restart our
application what if your product is the
stock exchange or maybe your product is
some military system while in your
developmental environment you can
restart your application as many times
as you want and you could do whatever
you want with it
a lot of times on production it's just
not going to pass so we can't use that
and the last problem that we might
encounter is something that at least
from my experience developers usually
don't think about or don't care about
and that's licensing a lot of these
tools don't allow their redistribution
to clients and that means that if you
use it on development it doesn't mean
that you can take it to your client or I
mean like maybe you could just take it
once for a one time debugging uh uh
debugging uh case but you certainly
can't redistribute this as part of your
application and even if redistribution
is allowed still you usually buy one
license for yourself or maybe multiple
licenses for your entire development
team but a lot of times your product
runs on tens hundreds or thousands of
production servers or clients or
wherever it is that your product is
deployed so obviously you can't buy
licenses which are usually quite
expensive by the way uh for that many
machines
so with that uh with that motivation in
mind it turns out that there's a
solution for all of these problems and
it's not surprising because after all
that's why we're here talking about it
uh and that's edw so edw event tracing
for Windows is a structured logging
framework incorporated into Windows
which supports hundreds of thousands of
structured log messages per second and
of course it doesn't have any of the
problems that we just talked about it
doesn't require any changes to your
application it certainly doesn't require
recompilation but it also doesn't
require restarting your application in
fact you could just turn it on on demand
whenever you want without having to do
anything and its overhead is very very
low if you don't turn it on at all the
overhead of each such call is a few
cycles and if you do turn it on then
well of course it depends on the amount
of data that you want to emit from this
uh from this
log and one of the best things about it
is that it's actually all over the
system as I said it's incorporated into
windows so you don't have to do anything
to get it it's just there lurking around
your system in user mode and kernel mode
it's in Services it's in uh net it's in
drivers it's it's even in third party
components in fact a while ago I found
out that even Chrome can Adit etw events
if you ask it
nicy
now although we don't have to go into
much detail in order to understand the
rest of my talk I do want to spend a
minute or two to give you an overhead an
overview of the architecture and how etw
is planned and structured just so that
you know you understand how the tool
that you use is working so the three
main components that you need to be
familiar with are providers controllers
and consumers the their names are pretty
indicative providers are those objects
inside your Windows system which are
responsible for generating the log
messages for emitting them from
different locations in the code the
controllers they're the ones that you
use to start stop configure all of your
loging scenario and consumers well they
consume they're responsible for logging
analyzing processing these log
messages the relationship between these
three components is it's not surprising
what happens is that the controllers
create an event
session and this event session receives
events log messages from multiple
producers and for performance reasons it
buffers them into an inmemory
buffer now the consumers they can
register on these events and consume and
analyze these events from the event
session now just one thing that I want
you to notice here is that from this
design it follows that in some cases
some events might be dropped because you
couldn't consume them fast enough or
there were too many of them coming into
the coming into the session so the
session actually holds the number number
of the of dropped events and you can
configure the size of the buffer pools
to a larger size if you think that it's
necessary for your
scenario okay now this is a screenshot
um from some of the uh providers from
the etw providers that I have on my
Windows machine the font is small it's
okay if you can't read it the point it
is that this is just a little part uh of
of all the providers and in fact on my
machine I counted slightly over a
thousand providers etw providers and
each of them can be configured with
different keywords and different
verbosity levels so there's there are
quite a lot of options that you can
configure and get exactly what you want
from the
system so now that we have a a little
understanding about what etw is and how
it's constructed um let's do a little
overview of uh different scenarios where
you can use edw to get information about
your
system so I think that the most common
thing that you can do with etw is
profile your application CPU wise um
what does it mean CPU wise which of the
functions are the heaviest ones on your
system now what you can see here is a
screenshot of an application called
perfum uh we will talk about it in
Greater detail later on for now just
know that it's an application that
allows you to easily analyze etw log
files and specifically in this case you
can see I highlighted two functions uh
one uh they both calculate prime numbers
uh one is managed and one is native and
together they take about 90% of uh of
the CPU time of your of of my
application um now the reason I have
here both managed is and Native is that
I wanted to show you that this
infrastructure allows you to Monitor and
profile both managed and Native
applications and that's very important
because obviously a lot of times our
applications are not purely
managed you can also use etw to get
information about garbage collection you
can get a list of all the garbage
collections that occurred in your
application how long they took how much
memory was uh was freed how much memory
was promoted what was the reason for the
garbage collection that occurred which
generation it
was further more you can actually get
the call Stacks of where each such
garbage collection occurred so for
example in this case we can see that
garbage collection was called excuse me
20 times due to GC ad memory pressure
and that probably means that our
application is using a lot of native
memory also garbage collection was
called 13 times during allocating object
and that means that probably our
application was using enough memory to
cause pressure on the CLR so that it
felt that it needed to invoke garbage
collection while allocating objects
what's even cooler than that is that you
can get call Stacks for the allocations
of each specific object type so what we
see here for example is a screenshot
again from perfum of all of the places
where a certain WPF application
allocated strings and it turns out that
this application allocated a gig and a
half of strings and some indexing
function now maybe it's okay in this in
this specific application maybe it's not
that's not the point the point is that
for me as a developer of this
application this is very useful
information if I want to analyze debug
and understand memory traffic issues in
my application I actually see where most
allocations occurred and that's amazing
uh in my opinion
you can also analyze long startup Times
by getting information about images
which are loaded by your application you
can also get information about the jit
times you can also get information about
file accesses that your application uh
that your application does again all of
that is very useful when you need to
understand what's going on inside now I
will go back a little bit to the CPU
profiling uh uh
scenario it turns out the etw not only
uh samples the CPU but it actually
provides all of the information per core
and that means that you can analyze your
application's concurrency efficiency so
this screenshot is actually taken from
the visual studio concurrency
visualizer um but the raw data that it
uses to produce this image is taken from
etw so what we can see here is an image
of our course and green means that the
core is running and red means that it's
blocked so we can deduce from this image
that there's probably something wrong
with our locking um model because it
looks like although we have four cores
de facto only single core is working at
each moment in
time and here we can see another image
where it seems that locking is is better
and the workload distribution is better
but it's still not perfect because I can
see that an entire core is working all
the time while a different core finished
its job in half the time so again etw
allowed me to see this data and
understand that I have something
suboptimal in my
application okay so that was an overview
and screenshots of uh of what we can get
using etw let's now go into a little
more detail into some of these
scenarios so going back to perfum uh
perfu is is uh an application by
Microsoft uh it rather recently became
open source so it's available on GitHub
for you you can view both the you can
just download versions or look at the
source code whatever works for you and
you already saw that it's not very
visually
appealing however it provides a very
convenient and functional UI for
configuring all sorts of etw collection
scenarios you can quite easily configure
the providers that you want to to
monitor the keywords that you want to
monitor the verbosity level that you
need and in fact it also provides you
quite easily to analyze these log uh
files later as you already saw using
multiple builtin St itical views inside
the
application now let's see uh let's see
something in action I want to profile
the process of starting visual studio
just starting Visual Studio itself no
solution no project uh no files anything
just visual studio so seeing that
profiling usually takes a lot time and
specifically open Visual Studio can take
a very long time I have a video video of
this demo so let's look at
it okay let me just stop it for a
second whoops okay look like that okay
so here I have per and what I want to do
is configure collection so I go to the
collect menu and here I can select all
sorts of stuff for example the size of
the memory buffers I'm going to make it
a little bigger just in case although I
didn't miss any events and this is
visual studio so you know I'm going to
click net and I'm going to click uh
kernel base which is going to give me
information about context switches in
the system and I want CPU samples
because I want to profile CPU
performance and I want to see what files
it accesses that might help uh shed some
light on what's going on
um I'm going to tell it to collect
symbols because I want to later look at
the call Stacks and see the function
names and I will give a different uh
file name it doesn't really matter um
and then I just start
collection now I'm collecting all of
this data and I can start visual
studio so I will start my visual studio
and of course I edited out all of the
waiting time believe me it took much
longer to to start
um and now that my scenario is done I
stop
collecting and then perf is just going
to load all of the files into it and I
can start looking so I will look at the
CPU stacks and I will select
specifically visual studio and we can
see that it actually took I don't know
if you noticed um take it a little back
um it took about 70 seconds until I
stopped uh until I stopped the uh
recording visual studio uh ran 70
seconds uh through you throughout this
time so let's understand what's taking
all the
time I'm looking at the list of
functions that were
called throughout starting visual studio
and I will go to call to the uh call
tree and that's my main main tread and I
see that the main tread uh ran for 40
seconds which is a little better than 60
and I will just start drilling down the
tree and this is the main function again
36 uh seconds going further down the
tree the col stack
tree takes a little
while it's a lot of data
there and further
down so by the way this is Visual Studio
I mean I didn't write it so of course
these functions don't mean a lot to me
but if it were my application that would
be very interesting information um and
then I get to this place where I see
that jet brains uh takes about 15 again
I'll go back a little I
apologize and we can see that a jet
brains function takes about 15 uh
seconds from my load time and again I
want to remind you that I didn't open
any solution or project of or file I
just opened Visual Studio from scratch
an empty visual studio so just putting
it out
there what else can we learn about
what's going on uh let's look at
jit so we have all the jit times from
the net applications and again I go to
the visual studio area and this time
I'll open the data in Excel um and I
will sort it by uh by the time that the
jet
took and you can see this J well this is
actually pretty long times but still it
might seem like a not very long time uh
but it actually adds up and considering
that it's all happening on the main
tread this is quite a problem uh that we
might be interested in what else can we
see we can see file
accesses uh or image loads for
example again specifically we select the
visual studio we can see all the images
that we loaded uh into our application
and again when it's Visual Studio we
don't have much to do about it but if it
were our own application we could you
know maybe find a way to optimize
this and it's sorted actually by the
size of the image so we roughly know
what are the heaviest images that we
load and which don't incur as much cost
as the
others okay that was useful I think so I
do have screenshots here in case
something didn't work with the demo and
so that later on when you look at the
slides you don't have to download videos
with it so we'll just continue to the
next section um what we did now was that
we used perfu in order to Define our
collection session but what if we want
to continuously monitor our application
on production and not not just come to
the customer one time and you know turn
it on do whatever we do and go back to
the office we want to continuously
monitor to our application for
performance issue well it turns out
there's a solution for that as well and
in fact uh in fact there's a nougat a
library uh you can get it's called Trace
event it's developed by the same guy
that develops perfu and actually perfu
uses that
Library uh and this Library Trace event
it provides a programmatic API uh for
configuring uh starting um analyzing etw
sessions and so for example what you
could do uh if you wanted to say monitor
your application for high CPU
performance uh usage uh you could do
something along the lines of monitor
continuously your application using
performance counters which just provide
a numeric value right so you know let's
say every second how much CPU your
application is using and once you detect
that your application passes a certain
threshold you can immediately configure
an etw session and collect some data for
a while either until the CPU goes back
down or for just you know a certain
predefined amount of time whatever works
for you so you record all of this data
and then you just you know ship it back
to development and analyze it and see
why suddenly your application was using
so much CPU and I do have to mention
here that I gave specifically the CPU
example but obviously it's not uh valid
just for CPU profiling you can do
similar things for any kind of limited
resource uh for example if you have
suddenly High memory usage you could you
know see where uh objects are being uh
allocated or if you suddenly have a lot
of Treads you can monitor where Treads
are being opened so let's see a code
example of how we can configure such
continuous
monitoring so it turns out that in etw
you can't use the same session for
kernel events and for user space events
so we're going to have to Define two
sessions one for the user stuff and one
for the kernel
stuff next I will need to Define what it
is that I want to record in each of
these sessions in each of these
providers so I didn't have room in the
slide for all of the keywords that I
wanted to use in the kernel session uh
but we're interested in processes in
Treads and file
IO and then specifically since I'm going
to monitor or manage application then I
know that I need to turn on the CLR
provider because I need information
about what's going on inside the CLR and
specifically I'm going to turn it on
with the verbas uh level uh and the
default keywords are going to be enough
uh enough for me at this uh at this
point now the session is going to be
closed when this once disos is called so
you know I just need to wait for
something to stop collecting it again it
can be either that enough time has
passed or you know the threshold of high
resource came down whatever it is uh
that's good for you and finally since I
want to be able to later analyze managed
call Stacks I will need the jit
information the jit rundown information
which will allow me to translate the
addresses into uh into net uh managed
functions so I will need this
information and getting this information
is actually quite easy again using etw
it turns out that there's a provider
called jit uh CLR rundown uh provider
and what happens is that once you turn
it on it just starts a
all of the jet rundown information that
the CLR saved along the way so again I
Define a session for this uh jit rundown
provider a CLR rundown provider um now
this is a little silly but the best way
I could find to figure out that all of
the information uh was written to my
file is that to check that it stopped
growing um so again this is a little
silly I didn't find anything better
um but the point is that after this is
done I know that all of the information
is written to my file and that's it so I
have the kernel information which gives
me sampling of the CPU which gives me
information about context switches about
processes I have the CLR information
which is going to provide me information
about memory usage and stuff like that
in my application and I have this jit
rundown information which will allow me
to
translate into into function calls all
of the uh all of the CLR
Stacks okay so again let's do a
demo and again since I don't want to
waste a lot of time I'm going to show
you a pre-recorded version with a lot of
stuff edited
out so I have an application here um
self- profiling application and what it
does is that I have two buttons or two
uh groups of buttons um one where I can
start uh you know crunching CPU time
using my application um and another
where I can start an etw session and
stop it so actually the code that showed
you before was taken from this
application so we'll run it for a
while I started profiling now I'm going
to start crunching CPU and and you can
see that there are high uh you know CPU
uh percentages and then I stopped it for
a
while once I finished my uh collection I
can see all of these files are created
these files are the ones that were
created for the sessions that we saw
before the kernel the CLR and the jit
and and the CLR rundown and now I open
again using perfu my application and I
see our two uh is prime functions so
this is indeed the way that I got the
screenshot from the beginning of the
slides and well not surprisingly it
turns out that calculating prime numbers
by simply dividing them but by all of
the numbers that are below them is not
the very uh efficient way of calculating
prime
numbers now while we're talking about
about looking at CPU uh information I
want to show you another very useful
application called WPA Windows
performance
analyzer this is also a tool which is
available for free uh from the Microsoft
website and straight away you can see
that it's uh much more visually
appealing um it's a it's really pretty I
would even say um and it provides a lot
of uh similar functionalities as per you
um but what I mostly like about it is we
have this area
here which is very similar actually to
the uh do Trace timeline view where you
can very easily select parts of your uh
process running and zoom in and out of
them and get information which is
relevant just for this time interval and
why do I like it so much it's actually
possible in perf few as well to Define
time intervals that I want to reduce my
data to but here looking at in a visual
way you can see straight ahead okay in
these five seconds I have a problem
right I don't want to get call stack
statistics about a range where I both
have a problem and not have a problem
because then the numbers that I see in
the call Stacks are not correct they
don't describe the problem and in
in WPA it's very easy with to see with
our eyes in you know in a split second
where the problem is reduce my range to
this area of my applications run and
then analyze
it the problem is that this application
is much less
lightweight um than perf few and so it
might take
longer so after I lo loaded symbols I
can start now uh going down the
callstack tree very similarly to uh to
perfum and even though I cut some of the
I edited out some of the parts here you
see that it takes more time to load but
eventually we will find our uh Prime
both native and managed functions in
this uh in this View and in fact another
thing that you can see here is when I
click on them it actually selects the
areas here on this uh timeline that
shows where these functions were called
so that's another reason I like this
View and now we can zoom out and the
table here will be updated to include
all of the data
again and you can see that when I click
S Prime you can see that it was only
called here and here so no calls to is
prime here in the
middle now another cool thing about WPA
is that it supports a different view of
uh of showing us CPU usage and that's uh
flame graphs so essentially flame graphs
are visual
hierarchial uh
views of coal stack
trees and and well this is obviously uh
a lot of information you can't get much
out of it but you can zoom
inside so first of all I'll filter just
to my application so this is a little
better uh but what it gives us is again
with a single glance an idea of what's
taking most time because actually all of
the information is here in this visual
tree and the higher the tree is it means
that the call stack is deeper and so the
bottom is like the main function that we
called and you can see on top of it all
of the subf functions that it called and
the width of each bar signifies the
amount of time that this function took
and so again visually it's very easy for
me now to look at this uh look at this
display and understand uh what's what is
the big picture here what's taking most
of the time and if I want to drill down
it's okay I can zoom in and you know see
all of that stuff okay it restarted
good cool so again I have some
screenshots here um just so that you can
later see
that so until now what we saw in the
demos is how we record log files and
then later analyze them using you know
some available tooling but it turns out
that you can actually add analyze your
data in real time and not just in
retrospect using these tools again we
can do that using the trace event
library that I mentioned before and the
idea is that there are um classes
parsers which are familiar with the
internal data structures with how the
payload of the different providers and
the different events looks so for
example you would have a CLR Trace event
parser which is familiar with the GC
event and it knows that the GC event has
let's say a type property and a
generation property and a reason
property and there's a kernel Trace
event parser which knows that there's a
process started event and it has a
command line arguments uh property and
it has a process name property um and
you can write your own these are
actually available built in inside Trace
event and you can write your own
parsers uh but if you don't feel like it
you can always fall back to using the
dynamic Trace event parser which just
provides a dictionary like uh API for
accessing any payload you want from
these uh from these events so let's see
an example a code example this is
actually taken from the official Trace
event documentation
and what we're going to see is how we
can monitor all of the processes that
start on our system in real time so we
start with creating a trace event
session that's not surprising and notice
here that I don't pass a file name I'm
not going to write it into a file I'm
going to consume it in real time I will
also register on the cancel key uh to
make it stop um because this session is
going to stop uh running once we uh stop
it otherwise it's just going to continue
forever so I want a mechanism that would
allow me to
stop and since we're interested in
processes which start and stop on our
system I'm going to specifically enable
the process keyword uh in this uh in
this session and of course I also need
to tell it what I want to do whenever a
process starts so since I'm using the
kernel uh provider uh
parser it actually has a process start
event and this is a type safe event
which has uh intimate knowledge of
what's going on inside the etw process
start event so like I said before it
knows that it has a process name
property and that it's a string and it
knows that it has a command line
property which is also a string it also
knows that there's a process ID which is
a number and so on obviously I didn't
have room here for all of the properties
but that's the idea and now we actually
want to start processing so we call
session process and this starts uh
passing the events to our event handler
and this call actually blocks until we
call session stop and so that's why I
had to register on something to stop
collecting if I don't ever want to stop
collecting that's also
fine now using what we just saw it's
quite obvious now that we can write our
own tool or incorporate it into our own
application that we can monitor
basically anything we want anywhere
anywhere we want um using these apis and
well luckily for for us we don't have to
do it ourselves because someone already
did that for us and there's an open-
source project called erce you can find
it on GitHub I put a link here um and it
provides a command line interface um for
configuring these etw live monitoring
sessions so let's see how it
works
excuse
me
okay there we have it so we have ER
Trace I already compil it beforehand and
what I want to do is that I want to
monitor all the processes that start on
my system so I tell it I'm interested in
the kernel provider and I need the
process keyword and the specific process
that I'm in uh event excuse me that I'm
interested in is process start and from
this specific event I'm interested in
process ID the image file name and the
command line arguments
so I'm going to run
that and I'm going to start a few
processes on my
machine I think that's enough and if I
go back to my command line I can see
that all of the information was logged
to the screen now the next thing that I
want to see is to monitor GC events
which we actually already saw before so
I turned on the GC monitoring and I
started this specific WPF
application and by the way I have a tiny
comment about this okay good so we can
see again that events are printed in
real time and this time I didn't pass in
any specific fields that I'm interested
in so it just prints all of the
information that the event has now just
a tiny comment I want to say do you
remember that application from the
beginning of the slides that we saw that
it was allocating a gig and a half of
strings so that application is actually
WPA maybe that's the reason it's not
very performant I don't know uh maybe
the WPA guys should run some etw on
their own Tool uh but anyway so we have
all of that GC information
here we can also do something
similar that's a lot of GC
okay
yeah so we can also do something similar
uh to what per um perf uh
um uh perfmon um not perfmon excuse me
um gosh I forgot its name in inter
internals there's a tool which provides
us information about file accesses that
application do I suddenly uh slipped the
name for my uh from my memory anyway so
we can also use eay to monitor file
accesses that we do on our on our
machine and so for this specific case I
want to monitor file accesses um
specifically uh opening files and I want
to um filter it just to dll files so I
can also provide a filtering um uh
expression for my uh for my tracing and
if I run
it and I'm going to open Internet
Explorer if I remember
correctly
yes
and now I get all of the DLS that
Internet Explorer accesses while it uh
it
opened so also a lot of stuff it's
actually not just limited to Internet
Explorer but you can see that Internet
Explorer is what caused caused this
surge of opening files now I do want to
mention at this point that you can't get
call stack information in real time and
that's because getting callstack
information depends on sampling the CPU
over time and then later analyzing it
along with the symbols information that
you have in order to create the call
stack uh the call stack trees so what
you can do in real time is Monitor just
the events themselves and if you need
small stack information you can record
this and then later analyze it with the
symbols and all the tools that are
useful for this now the last thing that
I want to show you is that even though
so far we did the live tracing using
erce it actually also supports analyzing
files so I have a file which contains uh
asp.net information about asp.net
requests um and the reason it's here is
both that I want to show you that you
can use erace to analyze files but also
that there's in interesting information
in etw regarding asp.net uh net servers
so I run it on my file and I can get all
of the uh
requests that happened during that
recording now again I just want to say
I'm showing this just to show you that
it's possible but I do think that if you
have uh a file which is already recorded
um and unless you absolutely hate you
know visual uis I would probably use
either perfum or WPA in order to analyze
existing log files uh the command Lane
interface is very useful for doing
realtime per uh
monitoring so again we have here
screenshots of our demo so the last demo
that I want to show you today is uh
monitoring and profiling boot
performance that's actually something
which is extra close to my heart um
because that was the first thing that I
did in my current job I investigated
boot performance quite a long time and
this is how I learned most of what I
know about
etw so we're not going to show a demo
because I don't want to start restarting
the computer and stuff like that um so
we'll just look at screenshots so WPA
Windows performance analyzer uh it comes
with a uh with a complimentary tool
called wpr Windows performance recorder
and what it gives us is a a very nice uh
compact uh UI for
configuring um all sorts of etw
collection scenarios and one of these
scenarios is boot profiling where you
can select Boot and you select all of
the resources that you want to monitor
while your application is booting now
remember until now what we saw is how we
record etw sessions way after the uh the
machine already booted and it's already
running and everything is in place so we
just start a session you know recreate
reproduce our problem and then analyze
it but how do you analyze boot you know
you can't wait for the machine to boot
and then start an etw session you
somehow have to make it record while
it's uh it's coming to live and there's
a there's a answer to that and that's
using Auto loggers so basically you
configure some Voodoo in the registry
and I mean it's not really wodoo it's
not very complicated uh you basically
say what's the file that you want to
save the etw session to you specify all
sort of parameters like the buffer size
and the max file size because you know
you don't want it to record forever and
uh and uh finish your disk um and then
you also tell it what are all the
providers that you want to record and
for each of these providers you can also
configure the verbosity and keywords and
so on so you configure this Voodoo in
the registry and once the computer
starts the one once Windows starts uh
booting it just starts emitting all of
these uh providers into the file that we
configured and after the machine is
booted you can look at these files and
see what was going on while the machine
was booting and what wpr gives us again
Window performance recorder is just a
more convenient UI for configuring this
uh Reg vuru now I do have to say though
that the UI is limited it doesn't
provide us all of the functionality
which is possible with this but just you
know for monitoring uh basic uh resource
uh usage scenario it's quite enough so I
configured wpr to monitor my boot and I
booted my
machine and I opened the results in
Windows performance analyzer and windows
performance analyzer similarly to uh
perfu it also has a lot of built-in
views which I encourage you to explore
later um for displaying all sorts of
information from our log files and in
this specific case it knows that we
recorded Boot and so it creates this
special view called boot phases which
shows us the flow of booting the machine
so for example we can see how how long
it took for the session to initialize
and how long it took for when Lon to log
onto the machine and how long it took
for explore to initialize and all of
these are are pretty fast but then
there's something called past boot which
takes quite a lot of time now in general
terms I
can I can say that past boot is kind of
like the time that it takes your machine
to calm down after it booted like you
know you start your Windows and you want
to open some applications but like the
computer is busy and you have to wait
until word opens or Outlook or whatever
so pass boot is the time that takes your
machine to go back to relatively low
disk and CPU usage
levels and this time is very long so I
want to use WPA and the information I
got from the etw to diag
knows what was going on on my machine
during this time and why it took it so
long to go back to normal CPU
levels so WPA also allows us to see a
lot of other things that happen during
Boot and can show us the drivers that
are loading the processes that start
running so for example there's a view
called transient transient process tree
and it displays us all of the processes
that started and stopped during boot
that's very useful information now in
this specific case I highlighted a
process called rabid Watchdog and it's a
little not fair at this point because I
wrote this process and I know that
that's the problem so I highlighted it
for you however how would you find out
what the problem was if you hadn't known
what was going on so there's also a view
displaying the CPU usage color
by the processes and here it is very
very
obvious that this rabid Watchdog is
what's taking all of the CPU time during
my booth process now again I wrote this
process I know what it's
doing um but say I didn't know or you
know maybe I did write the process or
I'm just not sure what on Earth takes so
long in my process that it consumes so
much CPU so I could use WPA to drill
down uh to the call stack tree but I
already mentioned that it's not very
efficient and it takes a long time so I
prefer using perfum to do that and if I
open my e my log file my etw log file
with perfume I quite uh conveniently
arrive to this point in the call stack
tree and I see that 99% of the time in
in this rabid Watchdog application is
spent getting processes running on the
system so I guess that the process
deserves its
name Okay cool so we're almost done here
that was our last demo um what are the
main takeaways that I want you to get
from this uh from this talk well first
of all I want to say that etw is an
omnipresent component in your Windows
system it's everywhere it's in services
in drivers it's in your applications
even though you didn't ask it to be
there it's just there and I actually
didn't mention it but you can write your
own etw logs and thus help your uh
production Engineers or whatever uh to
more easily monitor your
applications uh as needed uh
its performance is very good and in fact
I didn't mention it but more and more
profiling tools nowadays turn to etw as
their source of data I know for a fact
that uh Trace uses etw at least for some
of its information we also saw in the
talk that the visual studio concurrency
visualizer uses etw as its source of
data about uh CPU usage
so it's a very convenient and uh
flexible tool and again it's free you
can use it in
production you're not uh limited to the
number of computers where you want to
use it you don't have to decide
beforehand if you want to use it um you
can just come there turn it on whenever
you want and collect your performance
data so that's it um the final word that
I want to say to you about this in uh
this uh
etw is that unfortunately and that's I
think the major drawback of using that
is that there's very little or even none
at all documentation about
etw so for example when I was
researching boot performance basically
what I did was like you know turn on all
of the providers all of the keywords
everything recording everything and then
started like you know manually going
through log files trying to understand
what the different properties mean um
what's what's you know what's useful for
me what I don't need what's the minimal
number of providers and keywords that I
need to configure in order to get the
data that I need um and so if you decide
to use ITW you are probably going to end
up doing some digging and trial and
error in order to get to find the
information that you need however I I
hope that I did you know show you enough
advantages um so that the next time that
you have a performance mystery and the
next time that you decide that you need
to monitor your application you will ask
yourself can I do it with etw how can it
help
me thank you so much um
I hope you're hooked on etw now um I
think we have a little time if you have
questions I'd be happy to
answer yeah so the question was how we
can see all the sessions um
unfortunately there's something wrong
with my Windows machine so I can't show
you uh but somewhere there in the
configurations under um if you go to
Perman um there's a list of uh data
collectors or something like that there
um and you you know what I'll try let's
see if I can turn on my windows and see
what happens uh but in any case there's
a list there and you can see all of them
and the information I'm pretty sure you
can also see uh what's turned on in that
specific
session um if you can ask if you want
more questions you can ask while I open
my uh my Windows machine
um is it safe the another question is it
safe to disable them
all you know I don't think your computer
is going to explode and so in that sense
it's safe uh but Windows itself does
configure stuff I mean like if you just
you know even if you don't configure any
session of your own and you open this
view with the sessions you will see that
stuff are is running and moreover you
will also if you go to the registry to
the area where the uh Auto loggers are
defined you're going to find quite a lot
of entries there and so you're going to
ask yourself hm where did that come from
so you can turn it off then obviously
the application that's using that data
is not going to be able to do its work
uh but I don't think anything is going
to
explode so okay good event Trace
sessions and here's the list of sessions
you can see which one is running um you
can see properties you can see the
keywords which are configured inside so
the information is available for you I I
I wouldn't stop it though it's you know
Windows wants it so let it have
it okay cool thank you so
much
and I hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference